[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
[Musik]
guten abend hinein ein schwerer
holztisch ein paar fähnchen ein
blumengesteck das war der rahmen heute
für die hoffnung auf frieden ein
bisschen hoffnung und gleichzeitig die
einzige im moment in antalya an der
türkischen mittelmeerküste trifft der
ukrainische außenminister seinen
amtskollegen aus dem land das gegen
seines krieg führt eine stunde 40
minuten reden die beiden am ende kein
durchbruch aber auch kein grund deshalb
nicht genau hinzusehen es steht schlicht
zu viel auf dem spiel jörg brase ist vor
ort in der türkei
für ihn sind diese bilder ein trio
mevlüt cavusoglu türkische außenminister
holt die kriegsgegner zusammen an einen
ort auf regierungsebene zum ersten mal
seit dem russischen einmarsch ein
diplomatischer erfolg für die türkei die
gespräche aber sind es nicht es folgt
der versuch dennoch ein halbwegs
positives fazit zu ziehen
dieses treffen fand unter nicht
einfachen umständen statt es gibt einen
krieg es gibt einen großen konflikt das
ist der kontext in dem dieses gespräch
stattfand ich kann aber sagen dass es
ein äußerst zivilisiertes treffen war
nicht
zivilisiert zwar aber durchaus frostig
so muss man sich die stimmung wohl
vorstellen die geherrscht hat im fünf
sterne hotel an der türkischen riviera
danach geben beide eine pressekonferenz
getrennt die ukraine im linken saal
russland im rechten und die ganze welt
schaut zu wartet gespannt auf
konstruktives einen kompromiss gab und
hört vom russischen minister doch nur
bekanntes die ukraine verhalte sich
lange schon russland feindlich regiert
von neonazis hochgerüstet vom westen der
russland nicht verstehe
stolze was was die waffen versorgung der
ukraine aus dem ausland angeht können
wir sehen wie gefährlich unsere
westlichen kollegen vorgehen
einschließlich der europäischen union
sie verletzten alle ihre prinzipien und
so genannten werte sie fördert den
verkauf tödlicher waffen
die ukraine aber
in der region mario pohl werden frauen
von russischen truppen entführt ruft ein
ukrainischer journalist lavrov möge zu
geben dass dort schreckliches passieren
sie haben ihren auftritt gehabt lacht
der minister zurück sie kommen ins
fernsehen sie können sich widersetzen
vielleicht etwas freundlicher im ton
wird lawrow versucht haben auf seinem
ukrainischen minister kollegen klar zu
machen wer herr im haus ist cholera
tritt frustriert vor die presse und sagt
über konkrete maßnahmen habe labeouf gar
nicht reden wollen meinte
wir können diesen krieg nicht beenden
wenn das land das für diese aggression
diese invasion verantwortlich ist gar
kein interesse daran hat dass zu tun
ernüchterndes ende einer dienstreise
abtritt kollege abtritt lavrov einziges
ergebnis der krieg in der ukraine geht
unvermindert weiter
diplomaten ergaben sich nie sie machen
sich notizen heißt es so schön mit den
augen eines diplomaten guckte rüdiger
von fritsch darauf er war fünf jahre
lang deutscher botschafter in moskau ist
heute partner in der politikberatung
berlin global advisors herr von fritz
guten abend gute nannte sie was ja ein
durchbruch war das nicht heute in der
türkei können sie trotzdem da einen
funken hoffnung erkennen
ich gestehe das fällt schwer ich habe
mir die pressekonferenz des russischen
aussenministers angeschaut und bin aus
dem was er gesagt hat nicht zu dem
schluss gekommen dass die russische
seite es mit verhandlungen wirklich
ernst meint nicht zum einen hat er jene
ultimative forderung wiederholt die der
ukraine gestellt worden sind
zusammenhang der aggression russlands
gegen die ukraine nämlich dass das land
demilitarisiert und den offizier werden
soll das juwel territorium abgeben soll
dass die ukraine neutralisiert werden
soll und zugleich hatte er gesagt und
das finde ich ja dann doch mehr als
enttäuschend dass dieses forum nicht das
richtige wäre umfassen schüchtern zu
verbringen wo zu treffen sich dann
außenminister muss man sich fragen
vielleicht war serbien live als eine
gute gelegenheit eine solche
pressekonferenz zu nutzen um ein
klassisch britisch russische banja
schuld last umkehr zu betreiben die
andere seite zu bezichtigen sie seien
schuld der westen sei schuld
irgendwelche neuen vorwürfe aufzutischen
und das alte mär von der bedrohung
russlands solche ukraine die alte mehr
zu wiederholen sie würden also sagen das
war auch von russischer seite so was wie
eine pr show heute
lege sagt ich kann nicht erkennen dass
es wirklich ernst gemeint ist für
diplomatische lösung im sinne von
gesprächen bedarf es zweier seiten dass
das ein problem die ukraine sagt ganz
klar sie will solche gespräche und ihre
bedingung dass ein waffenstillstand ist
ja nun wirklich das nächstliegende er
sagt dafür sei das forum nicht vorhanden
dann fragt man sich wurzel diese
gespräche führt kann denn der russische
außenminister überhaupt selbst
entscheiden oder muss er sich für alles
was er da tut immer erstmal
rückendeckung im kreml bei wladimir
putin holen
der russische außenminister ist nicht
unabhängig in dem was er tut der kann
auch nicht lösungen verabreden die er
später dann versucht endgültig mit
seinem präsidenten zu befestigen wird
salopp gesagt an der ganz kurzen leine
geführt und mein eindruck ist überdies
dass in der gegenwärtigen situation auch
der russische außenminister gar nicht so
genau weiß wohin sein präsident steuert
nicht wir haben es ja im kern betrachtet
gar nicht mit einem krieg russlands
gegen die ukraine zu tun so mit dem
krieg und den obsessionen und der
verzerrten wirklichkeit wahrnehmung
eines mannes des russischen präsidenten
gegen die ukraine das heißt eine lösung
wenn es denn eine lösung geben kann
überhaupt geht nur wenn sich die beiden
präsidenten direkt treffen
man soll die hoffnung nicht aufgeben und
politik muss immer an die stelle von
militärische aggression treten aber
solange die russische seite ultimativ
auf diesen forderungen bestätige ukraine
nicht erfüllen will und aus gründen die
ich sehr gut nachvollziehen kann sondern
das extrem schwierig der russische
präsident wird davon auch nicht abgehen
worden
nicht sein ziel ist es diesen krieg zu
gewinnen das drama ist dieser krieg denn
der russische präsident begonnen hat
dann der für ihn schlecht läuft dann
darf er nicht verlieren die großmacht
russland kann es sich nicht leisten
gegen ein
kleines land und es mal so auszudrücken
dass er angeblich auch gar nicht recht
existiert einen krieg zu verlieren und
zugeständnisse zu machen und sich
zurückzuziehen das würde auch seine
eigene machtbasis zu hause gefährden
oder schwächen und das ist so schwierig
wie
das klingt jetzt nach nach wirklich viel
aussichtslosigkeit ehrlich gesagt gibt
es irgendjemanden der offliner die mir
putin dennoch einfluss nehmen könnte
dass ich gegen sie stellen gut der
hessische wirtschaft also zum einen
natürlich sind das internationale
initiativen seien seitens der türkei
israels oder fremdenhass ich denke der
chinesische präsident ist jemand der mit
dem russischen präsidenten gut darüber
sprechen kann wenn wir an innerer
russisches denken dann
fürchte ich dass die repression soweit
ist dass wir zumindest für den moment
nicht davon ausgehen können dass quasi
ein breiter massenproteste sich gegen
den russischen präsidenten erhebt dafür
bedarf es noch einiger verschlechtern
land im meer aber sie haben zu recht
darauf hingewiesen möglicherweise aus
dem militär sollte der russische
präsident weiter eskalieren sollte er
den preis für die armee immer weiter
hochtreiben dann bleibt die hoffnung
dass ihm seitens des militärs in den arm
gefallen wird
jetzt gibt es heute meldungen dass der
ehemalige bundeskanzler gerhard schröder
offenbar oder angeblich muss man sagen
eine vermittlungsmission in russland
startet und auch schon in moskau sein
könnte aus ihrer sicht ist das schon
diplomatie oder ist das image rettung in
eigener sache für schröder
also ich lasse mir den letzten teil
ihrer frage unbeantwortet aber
grundsätzlich gilt natürlich dass jeder
ernsthafte versucht diese schreckliche
aggression russischen militärs gegen die
ukraine zu beenden hilfreich ist wenn
ein ernsthafte absicht erfolgt und und
das hat sich die grundvoraussetzung
beide betroffenen parteien dem
vermittler vertrauen und darauf kommt es
am ende an rüdiger von fritsch war lange
deutscher botschafter in moskau
herzlichen dank heute abend im heute
schon mal dass die bahn zwar sehr gerne
ins gespräch aber aus termingründen am
frühen abend aufgezeichnet gucken wir
auf die lage vor ort jetzt in der
strategisch wichtigen und von russischen
truppen belagerten stadt mariupol im mit
osten der ukraine ist sie besonders
katastrophal und das schon seit so
vielen tagen dass wir schlimmstes
befürchten müssen das sind nicht nur
worte das kann man sehen diese bilder
zeigen wie es vor dem krieg aussah und
wie danach in kiew in ihre pin inaktiv
sinnlose zerstörung
und dann gestern mario pohl der
russische bombenangriff auf eine kinder-
und geburtsklinik dort ein abscheuliches
kriegsverbrechen sagt der eu
außenbeauftragte heute russlands
außenminister läutet den angriff nicht
dass es dort zivile opfer gab aber schon
die lage heute haben anna kleiser und
petra auto im blick
keine familienangehörigen keine
trauernden es sind mitarbeitende des
städtischen sozialdienstes die hier in
mario pohl die toten begraben nicht
wissend wien und mich zählen wie viele
alles was ich will ist dass das aufhört
ich weiß nicht wer schuld ist und wer
recht hat er damit angefangen hat
verdammt sein die das angezettelt haben
was ich fühle ich muss halt weiter leben
mario pohl eine großstadt ganz im osten
des landes für russland strategisch
wichtig seit mehr als einer woche von
der versorgung abgeschnitten kein
rauskommen mehr möglich die bomben
gestern auf die geburtsklinik sie lösten
weltweit entsetzen aus die russen
dementieren ein angriff auf zivilisten
sie hätten gedacht im gebäude seien
soldaten nicht werden die mütter so
sagen sie es
wie immer sie lügen ohne mit der wimper
zu zucken kriegsverbrechen sind nicht
möglich ohne propagandisten diese
vertuschen
dieser krieg macht angst jeden tag mehr
nicht nur den menschen in der ukraine
das atomkraftwerk tschernobyl in
russischer hand teilweise ohne strom
auch die reaktoren von taborea sind von
russischen truppen besetzt schon seit
tagen und sie bewegen sich auch richtung
atomkraftwerk süd ukraine am abend
melden russische medien sie wollen nun
repa touren an der stromleitung in
tschernobyl ermöglichen auch der
internationale atomenergiebehörde ist
verhalten optimistisch
beide seiten sind einverstanden dass es
sich lohnt die idee gemeinsamer
gespräche weiter zu verfolgen
die russische armee sie rückt weiter vor
in richtung kiew heute ein rückschlag
ein ukrainischer drohnenangriff auf eine
russische panzerkolonne gut 30 kilometer
vom stadtzentrum entfernt hohe verluste
sagt der mann am funkgerät sie haben auf
uns gewartet es war ein hinterhalt der
regimentskommandeur ist tot
in kiew haben sie straßensperren
errichtet um die panzer abzuhalten und
der bürgermeister er macht seiner
bevölkerung mut die stadt zu verteidigen
wir bereiten uns darauf vor dem
aggressor der in das herz unseres
staates vordringt eine abfuhr zu
erteilen
doch noch immer versuchen auch viele zu
fliehen die hälfte der bürgerinnen und
bürger soll die hauptstadt bereits
verlassen haben
was tun diese frage halt heute abend
durch die prächtigen seele von schloss
versailles
krisentreffen der staats und
regierungschefs der eu die ukraine will
hier mitglied werden und zwar schnell
eine guten abend das wird so nicht
klappen hast du vollen schon bei markus
lanz gesagt welches angebot kann die eu
dem land der ukraine den stattdessen
machen
die staats und regierungschefs und
chefin werden natürlich wortreich
beteuern nach ihrem treffen dass die
ukraine teil der europäischen familie
ist die werden der ukraine anbieten dass
sie künftig vielleicht als informeller
gast an eu gipfeln oder minister treffen
teilnehmen kann sie werden ihr auch
anbieten am studenten austauschprogramm
erasmus teilzunehmen natürlich nach dem
krieg und sie wollen versuchen auf alle
möglichen weisen die ukraine anzunähern
an die europäische union
aber sie werden eben nicht das angebot
machen das ist ein super schnellen
unbürokratischen beitritt der ukraine
zur europäischen union gibt die eu ist
nicht bereit den prozess den es dafür
gibt und der langwierig und bürokratisch
ist über den ball über bord zu werfen
weil sie sagt wir sind ein verbund von
rechts staaten und wir können nicht
einfach dieses recht über bord werfen
auch mit blick auf die
beitrittskandidaten auf dem westbalkan
die seit langem warten und deshalb wird
es keine sonderregelung für die ukraine
geben es wird eine assoziierung + + +
geben also wir wollen euch dabei haben
wir werden euch wirtschaftlich moralisch
politisch unterstützen aber einen
schnellen beitritt den wird es nicht
geben und dann andere die frage ob
russische energie importe nach europa
gestoppt werden sollten da tun sich
innerhalb der eu jetzt risse auf jedes
land ist ja auch in anderer weise von
dieser energie abhängig wird es dann am
ende eine gemeinsame eu energiestrategie
geben
man könnte fast daran glauben wenn man
das abschluss gipfelpapier ließ da steht
nämlich drin wir sind uns einig dass wir
die abhängigkeit von russischem gas öl
und kohle auslaufen lassen wollen das
ist für die europäische union schon ein
relativ revolutionärer satz aber es
steht eben kein jahres dathe und keine
jahreszahl in dem gipfel papier drin das
heißt jedes land wird weiter seinen
energiemix weiter bestimmen und da
beginnt eben die
uneinigkeit zwischen den europäischen
mitgliedsstaaten es gibt einige länder
deutschland österreich ungarn die schwer
abhängig sind von russischen
energielieferungen auch die
industriestaaten im westen und die
treten auf die bremse und sagen wir
können uns ein öl embargo sowie die
amerikaner es vorgemacht haben einfach
nicht leisten dazu kommt noch ein
weiterer punkt dass die eu selbst so ein
bisschen erschrocken ist über das
funktionspaket dass sie in solcher
windeseile beschlossen haben sie wollen
jetzt erst mal abwarten welche wirkungen
die sanktionen zeigen auf die russische
wirtschaft und eben auch welche folgen
das für die europäische wirtschaft hat
und wollen nicht gleichzeitig auf alle
knöpfe sozusagen drücken und erst mal
abwarten welche folgen auch das
ölembargo der amerikaner hat und sich
dann in der hinterhand halten dass man
vielleicht später auch noch selber
nachlegt aber moment wollen die europäer
erst mal abwarten wie die beschlossenen
sanktionen wirken werden danke schiffe
dieser analyse wie weit wird putin gehen
fragen von wulf schmiese an michael roth
den vorsitzenden des auswärtigen
ausschusses im heute-journal update um
23 uhr 50 wir bleiben noch beim thema
hanna du hast die zusammenfassung und da
blicken wir richtung westbalkan
aktuelles bundes außenministerin
baerbock im kosovo und sagte nach einem
gespräch mit ministerpräsident kurt ii
deutschland reiche den staaten in der
region die hand auf dem weg nach europa
zuvor hatte berbalk bosnien herzegowina
besucht und sich auch dort schon für
eine engere bindung des landes an die eu
ausgesprochen
nach einem treffen mit ihrer
amtskollegin
curkovic sagte baerbock dass
bosnien-herzegowina zu europa gehöre das
müsse intensiver an einer eu
beitrittsperspektive gearbeitet werden
gleichzeitig warnte berbalk vor einer
destabilisierung der region die
aussenministerin reagierte damit auf
abspaltung bestrebungen der bosnischen
serben die von russland unterstützt
werden
in keinem anderen eu land kommen aktuell
so viele ukrainische flüchtlinge an wie
in polen bundesinnenministerium feser
hat ihren polnischen amtskollegen
kaminski deshalb weitere hilfen zugesagt
das land solle logistisch unterstützt
werden sagte faeser nach einem treffen
an der polnisch ukrainischen grenze
dabei geht es auch um die weiterreise
von flüchtlingen in andere eu länder und
auch us vize präsidentin harris war
heute in polen zu gast in warschau traf
sie unter anderem präsident bruder und
versprach diesen ebenfalls unterstützung
die bildungsministerinnen und minister
der bundesländer wollen geflüchtete
kinder aus der ukraine möglichst schnell
in schulen unterbringen gleiches gilt
für kindergärten hochschulen und für
auszubildende
die vorsitzende der
kultusministerkonferenz prien sagte es
solle außerdem geprüft werden wie
ukrainische lehrkräfte und erzieher
dabei helfen können wenn sie den
menschen in der ukraine und denen auf
der flucht helfen wollen können sie
spenden zum beispiel beim aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe
ich war zdf nothilfe ukraine die bahn de
65 104 106 100 104 106 100 alle infos
auch unter spenden punkt zdf.de oder im
zdf text auf seite 8 190
wir in moskau petersburg oder jakub den
russischen krieg gegen die ukraine krieg
nennt und nicht
spezialoperation wer die invasion dort
invasion nennt und nicht befreiung
riskiert drakonischen gefängnisstrafen
wenn der in russland sehr populäre ex
modern talking star thomas anders seinen
russischen fans erst mal klar machen
muss was da in der ukraine überhaupt vor
sich geht dann kann man sich vorstellen
wie wichtig unabhängige information ist
auf russisch für russinnen und russen in
aller welt christian hübscher zeigt den
tele kanal ost west aus berlin
konstantin geht gleich auf sendung der
journalist ist seit 15 jahren berliner
aber aufgewachsen in moskau er moderiert
die russischsprachigen nachrichten des
tele kanal mostfest
auch er schläft seit zwei wochen
schlecht spürt die last in diesen zeiten
ein russe zu senken für diesen krieg
will ich nicht verantworten
verantwortung tragen
aber irgendwie muss ich
mich
rechtfertigen
vor mir selbst und auch plötzlich vor
den anderen
unabhängigen news auf russisch
produziert von einem team aus russen
ukrainern kasachen in berlin sie haben
geweint hier am tag als putin die ersten
bomben auf die ukraine fallen ließ und
dann haben sie ihren job gemacht haben
das verbotene wort wenn also krieg
gesendet wo für journalisten in russland
mit gefängnis rechnen müssen
jetzt sind wir plötzlich einer der
letzten unabhängigen
russischsprachigen kanäle auf der bild
ab 6 uhr morgens bekomme ich anrufe aus
der ukraine aus russland von meinen ex
kollegen die aus russland fliehen und
die irgendwo in armenien oder in der
türkei sind und die mich um rat fragen
was sie jetzt tun sollen
sie finanzieren sich seit 30 jahren
durch kabelnetz abonnenten und werbung
berichten für die russische community in
deutschland und weltweit noch immer sind
sie auch in russland über das internet
zu empfangen doch bei youtube mussten
sie kürzlich die kommentar funktion
abschalten wegen zu viel hass aus der
heimat so der geschäftsführer
die unterstützung putin sehr viele sehr
viele unglaublich viel längeren das ist
natürlich eine von unserer aufgaben zu
zeigen leute schaut mal das land so gut
isoliert von die ganze welt eher
wirtschaftlich politisch macht die
gruppe oder augen auf schauen sie was da
passiert was machen die in der ukraine
die hatten russische sonde hat die ganze
jugend die strände 1000 weise zu was
die russlanddeutsche valeria berichtet
über die sanktionen gegen russland und
findet sie richtig
weil vielleicht dieser druck auf die
bevölkerung den es gerade gibt
vielleicht bewegt die menschen dazu
aktiver gegen diese politik auf die
straße zu gehen zur wahrheit gehört auch
ein zurück nach russland ist für sie
alle hier auf absehbare zeit nicht
möglich wir verstehen ganz klar dass das
leben wie es bewerber wird nie mehr
geben und das land wie es führer wird
auch nie mehr geben moskau weiter ich
bin moskauerin ich liebe meine stadt ich
liebe russland ich verstehe das alles
aber das einzige was ich jetzt tun kann
ist arbeiten
der kriegt tut weh auf beiden seiten aus
berlin senden sie jeden tag auf russisch
der gegen ali baba die auf viele sind
der krieg in der ukraine setzt auch die
europäische zentralbank unter druck die
ezb belässt ihren leitzins im euro raum
auf dem rekordtief von 0 prozent trotz
der hohen inflation fragen wir nach bei
valerie haller an der frankfurter börse
valerie begründet die ezb in ihrer
entscheidung ja so vor allem damit dass
die lage ja noch sehr unsicher ist die
ezb und andere notenbanken sind in einer
ganz schwierigen gemengelage eine
zinserhöhung ist zwar angezeigt um die
hohe inflation einzudämmen andererseits
riskiert sie damit den aufschwung
abzuwürgen ein aufschwung der nun ja
zusätzlich gefährdet ist der krieg werde
erhebliche folgen für die konjunktur im
euro raum haben meint ezb-präsident in
lagarde wie stark hänge von der weiteren
entwicklung des konflikts ab einige
prognosen sind dabei jetzt schon völlig
überholt so schraubt die ezb ihre
wachstumserwartung für die eurozone
herunter auf 3,7 prozent die
inflationsprognose hingegen steigt
rapide um über zwei prozentpunkte auf
nunmehr 5,1 prozent trotz der unsicheren
lage hat die ezb die weichen für eine
leitzinserhöhung gestellt indem sie ihr
anleihekaufprogramm schneller
zurückkehrt als geplant danach könnte
eine zinserhöhung kommen wann genau ist
offen klar ist aber die notenbanker
gehen davon aus die inflation
verschwindet nicht so bald nach den
grossen gewinnen am aktienmarkt von
gestern fällt der dax heute wieder
deutlich minus drei prozent die ezb
zögert noch die amerikanischen notenbank
hingegen steht schon vor der zinswende
eine wahl hat sie kaum die inflation in
den usa liegt inzwischen bei fast acht
prozent so hoch wie seit 40 jahren nicht
vielen dank valerie nach frankfurt
und jetzt noch ein blick auf die zahl
der korona neuinfektionen die hat in
deutschland nämlich einen neuen
höchststand erreicht das robert koch
institut verzeichnete
262 1752 neue fälle innerhalb eines
tages das sind rund 52.000 mehr als vor
einer woche auch die sieben tage
incidents ist weiter angestiegen auf
88,5
kann soll das thema jetzt wenn zur
verabschiedung eines medienmanagers das
staatsoberhaupt persönlich kommt um
reporterinnen und korrespondenten für
ihren einsatz zu danken
dann sagt das viel über den stellenwert
von freie presse es sagt auch viel über
den medienmanager thomas bellut war zehn
jahre lang zdf-intendant einer der
dieses programm das sie gerade
eingeschaltet oder angeklickt haben
geprägt hat und zum marktführer machte
in deutschland journalismus ist
überlebenswichtig das hören wir
nachrichten leute gerne vom
bundespräsidenten noch besser wenn es
auch die feste überzeugung von möglichst
vielen zuschauerinnen und zuschauern ist
gerade in einer welt in der autokraten
und kriegstreiber dem journalismus den
kampf ansagen susanne gelhard berichtet
der bundespräsident kam persönlich nach
mainz zum abschied von zdf-intendant
thomas bellut das thema der
pressefreiheit sei ihm ein großes
anliegen gerade wegen der bedrückenden
lage in der wir uns befinden
pressefreiheit ist das gegengift zum
totalitären waren zudem war die hoheit
über die gedanken von menschen zu
erlangen
pressefreiheit erzeugt das gegenteil sie
erzeugt gleichberechtigung durch wissen
enthüllung des absichtsvoll verborgenen
ermutigung zum aufgeklärten streit
pressefreiheit ist ein hart erkämpfter
und wie wir sehen immer noch umkämpfter
wert im zdf habe sich thomas bellut
stets für die pressefreiheit eingesetzt
dort begann er als journalist moderierte
als leiter der innenpolitik wahl und
sondersendungen machte mit einem kohl
interview zur spendenaffäre schlagzeilen
sie haben es als großes glück
bezeichnet 40 jahre im mediengeschäft
arbeiten zu können ohne druck von
behörden oder regierungen krieg in
osteuropa und zensur in russland lässt
sie dieses glück sicher noch viel mehr
basketball star dirk nowitzki
bescheinigte thomas bellut beim
internationalen emmy directorate award
letztes jahr die qualitäten eines guten
athleten talent ziele harte arbeit
wichtig um das öffentliche rechtliche
zdf auf einem umkämpften markt auf kurs
zu halten sie haben das cdf schlanker
und schlagkräftiger gemacht und den
aufbruch in die digitale welt
eingeleitet trotz der schwierigen
rahmenbedingungen ist das zdf nun seit
zehn jahren ununterbrochener markt
schon als programmdirektor entwickelte
thomas bellut aus einem sender eine
senderfamilie jünger und frischer auch
dank der heute show die bedankte sich
für seinen rückhalt bei politiker
beschwerden und anfangs schlechten
einschaltquoten er redakteur die
einschaltquoten und natürlich auch seine
sorge um den fortbestand der show
ansprach meint herbert so wurde mir
zumindest von meinem bm zugetragen wenn
ich jetzt zieht ihre ach wissen sie ich
habe hier jede woche so viel ärger am
hals auf dem lerchenberg kommen freitags
nach hause und gucke mir die heute show
an machen sie mal weiter egal wie die
quoten sind die sendung machen sie jetzt
nur noch für mich die gar nicht einfach
heute
für einen norddeutschen eine sehr hohe
dosis von lob bekommen da in meiner
heimat heißt es eigentlich nicht
getadelt ist klug genug so gesehen hab
es genossen vielen dank dafür
am dienstag übernimmt sein nachfolger
norbert himmler weiter reformieren
verjüngen sparen der job ist nicht
einfach
[Applaus]
die worte des bundespräsidenten heute
bei der verabschiedung von thomas bellut
sind auch rückhalt für all die mutigen
die sich wehren gegen zensur und
einschüchterung zitat frank walter
steinmeier wer das licht der
informationen aus sperren muss der
braucht offenbar finsternis für das was
er tut
das war unsere welt an diesem donnerstag
maybrit illner bespricht die lage in der
ukraine gleich nach uns unter anderem
mit den parteichefs von spd und cdu und
dem deutschen kommandeur der nato
einsatz truppe in litauen und wir
wünschen ihnen jetzt noch einen schönen
abend
zum beispiel mit norbert lehmann und
allen wichtigen von den paralympics
handarbeit hallo christian danke ja wie
heißt das olympische motto doch so schön
dabei sein ist alles auch wenn es keine
medaillen gibt das gilt natürlich auch
für die paralympics und für das deutsche
team das heute bei den alpinen ski
wettbewerben keine erfolge verbuchen
konnte marcel bergmann
als sich leander kressin riesen slalom
der stehenden klasse auf den weg in den
stangenwald macht kann er sich
ausrechnen dass er mit der
medaillenvergabe nichts aber auch gar
nichts zu tun haben wird die einbeinigen
sind derzeit leidtragende des systems im
ski alpin
da sie in einer klasse mit den
zweibeinigen staaten müssen und
natürlich chancenlos sind der 21-jährige
aus friedberg landet schließlich auf
platz 22 hätte aber in einer gesonderten
wertung für einbeinige wie es sie bis zu
den winterspielen 2002 in salt lake city
noch gab heute die silbermedaille
gewonnen als schnellster in zwei läufen
erreicht völlig überraschend der finne
santala die verdi das ziel vor dem
us-amerikaner thomas worch und dem
franzosen acht jahren bush
gut heute also mal keine deutsche
medaille aber morgen da gibt es ja
wieder biathlon wettkämpfe und über 12,5
km in der sitzenden klasse da hat sie
richtig gute karten anja becker die in
peking schon bronze geholt hat und die
stellen denen jetzt mal kurz vor
[Musik]
paralympics sind immer 14 tage
gänsehautmomente es ist irgendwie wie 14
tage träumen
mein name ist anja becker ich bin 30
jahre alt und meine sportarten sind
biathlon und langlauf
ursprünglich habe ich mit handbike
angefangen bei einem marathon habe ich
den jetzigen teamkollegen martin fleig
kennengelernt der mir eben gesagt hat
das ist auch langlauf für behinderte
gibt die handlung kam dann später dazu
und ich habe erst mal geschossen und
liegt gleich richtig gut und hat mir
super viel spaß gemacht und ich wusste
dass das wort mein ding sich auf der
strecke total auszubauen und dann mit
der ruhe am schießstand zu kommen die
herausforderung weil ich von anfang an
faszinierend ich bin von geburt an
behindert das hängt mir fehlen stück von
der wirbelsäule
ich bin in der zweitniedrigsten statt
klasse eingestuft lw 10 5 das weiß ich
bin mit am meisten behindert im
starterfeld eben weil ich wenig
rumpfmuskulatur habe und alles
eigentlich nur aus den armen und
schultern macht als ich jetzt wieder an
gold und silber geholt habe war total
verrückt und abgefahren versuch so
locker wie möglich in die paralympics
rein zu gehen so viel spaß zu haben wie
es nur geht nervosität ist aber das ist
meistens eine positive und die wandel
ich dann hoffentlich ein schnelles
laufen und gute schießen um
wir drücken die daumen für morgen china
ist ja bei diesem paralympics absolute
spitze führt den medaillenspiegel mit
zehnmal gold an das land hat in den
letzten jahren massiv auch in diesen
leistungssport investiert aber es ist
nicht alles gold was glänzt wenn es um
den ganz normalen alltag der über 85
millionen behinderten in china geht wie
uns jetzt christiane hoffmann und tibor
meingast zeigen
bewegung zur musik die funktioniert auch
im rollstuhl
im rote tanzschuhe kunstverein in peking
üben die frauen die choreografie für
ihren nächsten auftritt das jetzt bei
den paralympics in china menschen mit
behinderungen viel öffentlichkeit haben
gefällt ihnen gut
das ist unser aller traum dass menschen
mit behinderungen bei einer großen
veranstaltung auftreten können wir sind
sehr beschränkt beim sport aber wenn sie
ihre stärke zeigen dann ist es auch für
uns eine große ehre
aus angst verspottet zu werden haben
viele als kinder noch gleichaltrige
gemieden inzwischen fühlen sie sich eher
akzeptiert probleme aber bleiben die
bahn muss von ihrem mann aus dem tanz
keller zwei stockwerke nach oben
getragen werden einen aufzug gibt es
nicht in großstädten ist einiges
behindertengerecht aber noch lange nicht
alles
erstes zu eng für den rollstuhl wenn es
etwas breiter wäre könnte ich
ein problem ist das gleiche wie in
europa generell
kinderfreundlicher gebaut aber bei alten
bauten funktioniert es nicht so gut
anders als in den städten erleben
menschen auf dem land größere
diskriminierung der druck nützlich im
sinne der kommunistischen doktrin zu
sein lastete auf den menschen mit
behinderung 85 millionen davon gibt es
in china die frauen mit den roten
tanzschuhen sind ein beleg für
behindertenfreundlichkeit in peking aber
auch sie wissen es muss noch viel
verbessert werden
morgen der siebte wettkampftag in peking
bei uns zu sehen ab 31 im livestream der
riesenslalom der frauen da ist ja
anna-lena faster eine
medaillenkandidatin
und wir sehen uns morgen an wieder wenn
sie mögen
[Musik]
schon gut und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter so sieht deutschland unter
hochdruckeinfluss aus kaum eine wolke am
himmel dafür drifteten aus dem osten
einige wolkenfelder ins land lösten sich
aber rasch auf der hochdruck macht es
möglich ansonsten sehen wir hier in weiß
die alpen ist der schnee über den in den
bergen und kaum eine wolke am himmel
auch dort schauen auf die nachts kaum
eine wolke auch in der nacht dafür und
kräftiger südostwind der dreht im laufe
der nacht weiter auf und dementsprechend
fühlen sich die temperaturen in der
nacht auch kälter an minus sechs bis
minus 8 grad wären dann erwartet hier
grad ganz im westen deutschlands also
frostfrei morgen im tagesverlauf viel
sonnenschein aber weiterhin kräftiger
wind aus südöstlichen richtungen
ja und ganz im südwesten da kommen
einige schleierwolken auf arbeit bleibt
weiterhin trocken die trockenheit ist
ein problem denn wir haben es mit der
höheren waldbrandgefahr zu tun stufe 3
fast überall in deutschland nach osten
und südosten hin sogar stufe vier von
möglichen 5 die temperaturen erreichen
höchstwerte von 5 grad an der ostsee 4
grad in richtung südosten und 15 grad am
niederrhein die nächsten tage sind
weiterhin trocken und sonnig am samstag
gibt es im westen viele wolken sonst
aber weiterhin aufgelockerte bewölkung
mit sonnenschein bei 7 bis 15 grad und
am montag sogar bis 16 grad dafür im
norden einige tropfen damit ein schöner
abend